spinach pineapple avocado in the Kenyan
capital Nairobi healthy food is in
and the newest trend in superfoods
baobab powder people love using it in
smoothies
and the new super food comes from
eastern Kenya baobab trees as far as the
eye can see
up until very recently
James was selling orange juice at a
stand on the street before starting his
new job he had to learn how to climb
thousand-year-old bobble Bob's a coach
trained him to recognize weaker limbs
and balance his weight appropriately me
my name is Lee Chi hoon abandoning tea I
used to just climb up the small trees I
tried climbing up the bigger ones
but a lot of people fell down and died
just like that so I was afraid a baobab
tree needs about 25 years before it
starts producing the gourd like fruit
it's edible pulp also called monkey
bread is incredibly rich in vitamins and
nutrients in other words foodies think
it's hip but more importantly harvesting
baobab fruit helps people here develop a
sustainable source of income the fruit
used to only be eaten by locals but now
it's increasingly being sold in big
cities help us the most would be large
orders small orders like we've been
getting up till now aren't really worth
the work I think you know we took well I
leave it this is the powdery fruit is
tangy and extremely healthy ameesha
Patel a local Kenyan realized the
selling potential and started up a
baobab company four years ago since then
she's been buying up to sixty sacks a
year from James and his colleagues but
it's not only profit that matters to her
I would love to see the tree to be like
a national symbol or a protected status
because with the development that's
coming around we are afraid that it's
going to demolish the the trees that are
that are actually in Kenya Patel takes
her harvest to Nairobi
special machines separate the baobab
Pulver from the seeds the next step in
the process is pressing the seeds the
extracted oil is known for its
antioxidant effects and considered a
cosmetic miracle
so basically the whole process that is
involved here is zero waste we don't
waste anything from the entire process
right now Patel is trying to qualify for
organic labeling but she doesn't want to
export her product yet
it grows in Kenya it should be available
for Kenyans as well as well so I hope
that at some point hopefully within the
next five years
every Kenyan household should have a
packet of baba proof powder and now that
the fruits qualities have been
discovered
maybe Kenya will be able to protect the
ball above tree and it in turn will
brighten their future